we're gonna jump right into phone calls
a lot of people wanting to get on today
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we are starting
with the caller from 7 7 8 7 7 8 area
code Euron I just wanted to talk to you
about guns and mental health today all
right go ahead so talk to a veteran
friend of mine and he told me you can
own a gun in Canada you're 16 if you
take safety courses gun courses pastor
test ask the mental health check have
stream referrals people close to you
that are advocating that you're seeing
responsible you have a past background
check that's updated every day if
anything happens you get your Anthony if
you do anything that's serious and bad
get your guns taken away and your
parents have to buy your guns for you
until you're 18 so he's going to when
you're 16 17 the parents have to buy the
gun for you yeah there was a story in
Canada where a man was divorced he owned
guns and I don't know who called exactly
am I the government or a private entity
that knew that he owned guns I called
him and asked just you know if she
wasn't too upset or if he was
psychologically okay just make sure that
you know he doesn't do anything having
said that what what are you what are
your thoughts on what I just did
well listen about 16 17 or 18 I I don't
I don't really have any comment on that
piece in different parts of the u.s.
different state law you can have
different types of firearms at different
ages I think that the licensing and the
upkeep with the requirements is
absolutely crucial there's no reason
that firearms in the United States
should not be licensed as seriously as
automobiles are I think you should have
to have a particular type of insurance
if you own firearms I think that the
licensing requirements should be far
stricter obviously 100 percent
background checks of course the systems
can't be a patchwork remember one of the
shootings where someone actually wasn't
supposed to have guns but there was not
the right reporting
I think from state to federal or
something like that and it slipped
through the cracks so I think that
without question there needs to be an
infrastructure for licensing and
ensuring individuals who are going to
have firearms and I think that that
whether it's the exact model you
mentioned a reversion of it I don't know
yeah and I think that one one difference
between Canada and the US is that like I
said our background checks I think it's
well it's a bit it every day I'm not
sure that's what you guys out there but
it's anything if you do anything that's
bad right you know that gets updated we
can actually take the guns away and I
think because of your second Amendment
rights you guys sort of say no that can
never sort of happen now there are
situations where people have to give up
their firearms and very often they end
up getting them back and in fact was the
case in a recent shooting the problem
here is even if those records were
updated daily the patchwork between all
the different states and federal
I assure you means that even if they
were kept on a day to day basis they
would not be updated on that same basis
and it's it's an absolute disaster the
system we have really appreciate the
call very very interesting I think we
absolutely need need a system like that